and we go to a cocktail party which they
often have around Grammy time Oscar time
anytime
the times that I'm out
I can't worry about the dude that I'm
with on my date getting too drunk being
inappropriate I don't have time in my
life for that so it is time to put these
guys up to this test I'm gonna hook it
up what happened last time you had
tequila the Marine came out then that's
why I stick to vodka
but I'm gonna do whatever the lady wants
me to do as far as the drink goes I mean
at the end of the day I'm an alpha male
but I am very thankful and humble that
we're continuing our connection
yesterday was crazy me personally I feel
like people were intimidated when we
walked yeah
no I I don't mean I just said some
people were nah not at all
do it
okay y'all so now it's time to make the
pizzas so y'all gonna like get a pizza
and split it in half and do what you
want on one half okay now you get okay
it can be challenging when there's so
many guys and it's just one lady
surprise me love food you cook at home
then all the time all the time all the
time bro this is low-key like giving a
massage but you got the spank it yes but
I believe sometimes you just have to
hold back and hold still and your
presence still will be felt well how
you're gonna make your side bigger than
mine all right absolutely I'm playing
with you I don't know if she's a sauce
girl or not oh dang that's Saucy but it
is
yeah okay yeah man don't drop that don't
drop that right there
[Music]
cheers
it looks like y'all did a great job we
about to find out
try this one first I'm loving the
pepperonis already this one was yours
now I'm going to try you
oh that's tricky that's better
this one is the most interesting looking
child something about with the way the
cheese is settling on this crust this
has to be you yep
that is good so this was you yeah
I love a veggie pizza
I got them gloves
I plan to eventually be a vegetarian so
this is really really right up my alley
I'm loving it it's tastes amazing
you are quite a freaking mystery aren't
you
big inhale here we go
you guys can stop I see you worked up I
see a sweat let's go glistening okay so
this is called Evelyn circuit you have
50 Battle ropes jump rope boastable
push-ups and 10 burpees the first person
who finishes has the first one-on-one
date with me and we'll see what happens
with the other two let's get started
then okay are you keeping a score
because some of these notes you ready
you ready
you know I'm an OG you know I'm looking
at the new guys and I'm just like it's
about competition yes let's see what we
got let's go ready ready
set
go
[Music]
Evelyn is super into fitness loves
Athletics and once a guy who can keep up
with her in the gym Bring It On
that kind of nervous
let's go
YouTube
[Music]
you guys did so great